and though remembered today at least by
those of us who revere them
as the giants of the discipline boaz
and his students margaret mead ruth
benedict all of them
zora neale hurston were in their time
dismissed from jobs because of their
activism
denied promotion because of their
beliefs harassed by the fbi as the
subversives
they truly were and attacked in the
press
simply for being different and yet
they stood their ground he would never
sit back in silence as fully half
the languages of the world hover on the
brink of extinction
implying the loss in a single generation
of fully half
of humanity's social ecological and
spiritual knowledge
to those who suggest that indigenous
people are destined to fade away
he would reply that change in technology
is no threat to culture
but power is cultures under threat are
neither fragile
nor vestigial in every instance they are
living dynamic peoples being driven
out of existence by identifiable forces
that for him was an optimistic
observation because if
human beings are the agents of cultural
destruction
we can be and must be the facilitators
of cultural survival
so anthropology matters as it always has
because it allows us to look under the
surface of things
the very existence of other ways of
being other ways of thinking
other visions of life itself puts a lie
to those of us in our own culture who
say for example that we cannot change
as we surely know we must the
fundamental way
in which we inhabit this planet and as
the events of the last
years have shown the struggle long ago
championed by franz boaz
is lamentably ongoing
never never has the voice of
anthropology
being more important but it must be
spoken
to be heard